[Music]
we only have a small seminar this
time you has to know that
but we were talking dinner time we were
speaking dinner
time and you must understand it's not
aggressive it's a powerful art that
comes from your good feeling
it's very
[Music]
econom this person strong
strong you have to learn how to attack
his arm with your
body then you
control if you have a silent training I
don't think it's so good
[Music]
this is uh my my understanding
that we must use because
[Music]
I what my child
one one up one
[Music]
down so this means part of my body is
dead I'm I'm nearly alive
[Music]
only your child your body everything
you need to
[Music]
hold all
your so if you uh if you want to be a
good aroka I think it's good
to they
alive how evence
[Music]
you need to get to
here so this is why you need to have
that Dynamic
[Music]
opening the
it's
economical someone